chrissy teigen
i don't really know what chrissy teigen
does but she is all over social media
and she's frequently in the headlines
chrissy teigen is pregnant again
through ivf after she had a miscarriage
and i do remember when the story of her
miscarriage came out
so chrissy teigen
suffered a late miscarriage it's very
very sad and she mourned the loss of her
child
as a child and this was very very sad
and now
what was it uh
some months later at least she
or something years later i guess this
was actually a couple years ago she has
become pregnant again and now she's very
excited she said the last few years have
been a blur of emotions to say the least
but joy has filled our home and hearts
again
one billion shots later
in the leg lately as you see because
she's going through ivf we have another
one on the way
i
have a great deal of sympathy for
chrissy teigen
i i can't even really imagine how
terrible it is to have a miscarriage
that late
especially that late to have any
miscarriage really but especially that
late when you're you've you've invested
so much emotionally and physically into
this baby and then the baby is dies in
the womb it's very very sad and i'm i'm
happy for her that she will get to have
a baby
hopefully hopefully she'll get to have a
baby
the question then you gotta ask yourself
especially if you're
a supporter of abortion
first question why was chrissy teigen so
sad when she had a miscarriage
the pro-abortion people tell us that's a
clump of cells that's morally irrelevant
there's no it's no big deal it's it's a
parasite get rid of it
get rid of it and then go have a party
for how fun your abortion was
well if that's true
then chrissy teigen shouldn't be sad
then we should think chrissy teigen's
really weird for being sad over her
miscarriage why are you why are you so
sad it was just a clump of cells it was
just a random morally irrelevant
we have to grapple with that
only one of those two things can be true
only
it can either be the case that this is a
meaningless clump of cells or it's
really sad that chrissy teigen had the
miscarriage obviously the latter is true
and chrissy teigen is sad because that's
a life in the womb okay so we should
discard the pro-abortion talking points
and it's not like chrissy teigen is some
right-wing rock-ribbed conservative
she's a a cultural figure and i assume
she's on the left so the left should
take a minute and think about that okay
the value of chrissy teigen's child does
not just come because she likes the
child or she wants to acknowledge the
child child the the value has to come
from the child intrinsically but then
there's another harder question which is
if all that is true if chrissy teigen
is right to be sad over her miscarriage
it is because babies are babies from the
moment they are made not just from the
moment of birth not just at
eight months and 29 days
but babies or babies from the very
beginning
and if babies or babies from the very
beginning ivf is not morally acceptable
and this is a hard message and i know
there are a lot of conservatives who
support ivf and i know there are a lot
of even pro and not maybe not a lot but
there are a number of pro-lifers who
support ivf
and i know part of the reason for that
is people have benefited personally from
ivf
and people say well my child was was
conceived through ivf are you telling me
my child shouldn't exist no
sir i'm certainly not saying that it's
wonderful that your child exists
the child has value that the value of a
child is not determined by the way that
the child was conceived this this is why
we don't think we should just kill
people who are conceived through rape
and and i've got a podcast out right now
called the choosing life podcast where
you we talk to people who survive
abortions where uh you hear this
throughout the pro-life movement people
who are conceived through rape say
they'll confront pro-abortion activists
they'll say do you think that i should
be killed
just because no of course not the way a
child is conceived does not determine
the value of that child but
likewise it doesn't justify rape and it
doesn't justify
uh methods that are immoral good ends do
not justify immoral means and in the
case of ivf it's really hard to argue
that it's morally acceptable because ivf
there are lots of moral issues with ivf
but one of them is
you create lots of human beings lots of
little embryos most of which you just
put in a freezer forever
some of which you then implant in the
woman and then sometimes if too many of
them take
the ivf process will entail abortion to
reduce the number of embryos in the womb
there are all sorts of problems but even
at the most bait and there and there are
problems actually in addition to that
through the method at which these these
embryos are conceived but even the ones
that are just in the in the freezer
you're telling me life is sacred from
the very beginning and we're all
pro-life and a person's a person no
matter how small what about the babies
in the freezer
it's not
it's not acceptable i've racked my brain
trying to figure out a way in which ivf
can be morally justified i can't think
of it and then there's an even broader
political issue which is that it is not
a good idea i think to put
technology to establish the domination
of technology
or any kind of power a corporate power
or a state power to establish that
domination over the origin and destiny
of human life
that seems like it could go wrong really
fast it seems like it necessarily goes
wrong
really fast
and and i think most people
on most political issues are kind of
like chrissy teigen they hold views and
they engage in behaviors that are
contradictory
chrissy teigen
so publicly mourns her child who died in
the womb because a person's a person no
matter how small and then engages in ivf
and she probably has no idea that there
is a conflict there that there's a
contradiction there but it's important
for us to talk about it especially now
that we're in a post-jobs world we've
gotten rid of roe v wade we've gotten
rid of
planned parenthood vkc we can
acknowledge that babies are actually
babies we we've moved past kindergarten
the kindergarten level of talking about
pro-life and now we need to get to the
second grade level and now we need to
get to the fourth grade level and now
because it goes a lot deeper than just
don't murder babies in the womb if you
want to get rid of our culture of death
if you want to create a culture of life
it's got to go a lot deeper than that
we've got to talk about
what what life means why life has value
where babies come from what what the
relation of the sexes are what sexuality
means to the human person the
conversation goes much much deeper and
it is no coincidence
that
the
moment in our history that gave us
abortion the 1960s is also the moment in
our history that gave us the entire
sexual revolution promiscuous sex all
sorts of weird gender ideologies it's no
coincidence that those are all happening
around the same time because they're all
deeply related and we're not we're not
really going to solve any of those
problems individually until we have a
coherent view of what human life is and
why it ought to be
protected
i'm so glad you like that clip you know
we hit 1 million subscribers and that's
big i know but we don't want to rest on
our laurels we don't want to pat
ourselves on the back i want to hit 1
billion
i do so i really need you to ring
subscribe like click
myspace i don't know make sure you get
the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you